Rachida oui je voulais juste te parler
de quelque chose tout le monde t'attend
sur Tik Tok et partons pour lancer
Spotify et pourquoi faire pour débattre
pour échanger pour mettre en lumière les
Parisiens sur ce réseau social
ouais pourquoi pas ça
[Musique]
à bientôt
moi j'adore ce gouvernement en fait il y
a pas eu de meilleur allié du mouvement
social que c'est le bingo de la loose
toutes les conneries à faire ils les ont
faites méthodiquement les unes après les
autres et là aujourd'hui le 49-3 c'est
l'apothéose là si tu veux ils ont jeté
un baril d'alcool à brûler sur le
barbecue c'est formidable
[Musique]
dans ce qui s'est passé la passation de
pouvoir avec Monsieur Hollande
on n'a pas parlé de grand chose et je
pense que
ça s'est vu puisque
je l'avais accueilli à sa voiture et je
crois qu'il m'a pas accompagné nous
sommes dans un pays qui permet cette
expression de démocratiser sociale de
messages nous ne souhaitons pas de
blocage parce que les blocages
évidemment sont pénalisant pour tout le
monde
[Musique]
c'est dommage que des Sylla parce que il
aurait pu faire une carrière en or
Giscard à démodé Pompidou
Chirac a défendait moi j'étais un peu
démodé
on peut pas dire à François Hollande
qu'il est démodé qui que ce soit